دعوا لندن تعود الى العمل هكذا كان
الدعوات الالاف من اللندنيين في ثاني يوم
من اضرابات بقيت النقابات وتحذر منها طوال
الشهر الماضي لكن مع اسرار الحكومه
البريطانيه على التمسك بموقفها الرافض
لطلبات عمال النقابات يبدو انا لا املا
يلوح في الافق لانهاء الازمه التي تتسع
رقعه اضربتها محطه ووتر لو واحده من اكثر
محطات لندن ازدحاما بالمسافرين لكن مع
اضراب اكثر من 40 الف عامل في قطاع السكك
الحديديه تبدو هذه المحطه على غير عادتها
هذه انا نسبيا بعد الغاء العديد من
الرحلات بسبب الاضراب ريشه هناك وفي خطابه
الاول هذا العام نقابات الى التحلي
بالعقلانيه مشيرا الى ان الاضطرابات رغم
احترامه لاهدافها الا انها اصبحت تعرقل
حياه الناس
ورغم تعهد سوناك بالعمل على خفض التضخم
وتعزيز نمو الاقتصاد وفتح حوار مع
النقابات الا ان تعهداته الاقتصاديه لم
تكشف عن خطه واضحه لكيفيه تحسين اجور
العمال
اليد اعتقد ان الزياده بالنسبه 19% لا
يمكن تحملها وتشير استطلاعات للراي الى
تراجع دعم اضرابات السكك الحديديه الى اقل
من النصف بينما لا يزال نحو 66% من الناس
تتفهم اسباب اضرابات في قطاعات اخرى مثل
الممرضين وموظفي
الاسعافات وتخريبيه اكثر من كونها مفيده
ولابد من التعامل معها بعقلانيه نحن بحاجه
للمال والكل بحاجه
يؤثر على الجميع
دخل البريطانيون العام الجديد بكل زخم
لكنهم لم يجدوا لندن مستعده لهم اضرابات
قطاع السكك الحديديه هي البدايه لسلسله من
الاضرابات التي تهدد بها النقابات ومع
وعود غير واضحه من الحكومه في تحقيق مطالب
العمال يبدو ان بريطانيا مقبله على فتره
صعبه من غير الواضح خطوره متابعتها على
البلاد من لندن عروب عبد الحق العربيه